the minimalists want to help you avoid
impulse purchases that's why we created
five questions to ask before buying
which is now a wallpaper for your
smartphone
now you'll always have a reminder when
you're getting ready to purchase
something new
head on over to the minimalists.com
slash before
to download your free wallpaper today
is it acceptable if i intentionally
choose not to vote
jonathan i think it's absolutely
acceptable if you choose not to vote
and my question to anyone who would
disagree with that is okay then
would you like to make it a law
requiring people to vote if you believe
that it's so unacceptable
if you believe that people ought to do
it and it's some sort of blasphemous
unforgivable sin
then do you believe there should be a
law that requires people to do this
morally good thing
if you do i want to hear what that
argument looks like i'm interested
that's australia
yeah yeah a lot of countries have that
yeah yeah and i like to hear
from those who think you should have it
i'm adamantly against what i think
they'll be the antithesis of freedom but
if you don't believe that it's a law
then you absolutely have the right to
choose not to vote right
and for me i don't believe in
validating systems based on
a need to assuage the guilt that other
people might impose upon me
if i'm going to do something it's
because i believe in that system for
myself
and i believe that what i'm doing
matters now you can't make a decision
based on my belief
you don't believe what i believe you
don't know what i know maybe you haven't
experienced what i've experienced but
if you're going to do anything at all
whether it be voting or not voting
you ought to do it based on your own
research on your own reflection
not because someone says i'm not gonna
approve of you
if you don't bow down and worship the
nation's true god
right because that is the true god of
this nation sure give lip service to the
idea of
this being a christian nation but you go
talk to people about jesus christ or
about the bible and
you'll find out really quickly that we
don't tolerate people who preach about
things yeah ready to tell us what to do
the only thing you can get away with if
you want to preach in this country is
that
go out and vote so that's the true
religion and i don't think you should
follow any religion
you know based on people trying to
guilt-trip you yeah what would you say
and let me start with i have not voted
in more elections than i voted
with uh for a lot of the reasons you've
seen so this isn't coming from an
argument place but
what would you say if i don't think it's
taking away your freedoms i think it's
taken away your freedoms if they tell
you how to vote or if it's like here or
two candidates you're forced to vote for
one of them
but what would you say if it was let's
say a law
um that you had to vote but because of
that because now
millions more people are involved and
invested that maybe we also make it
a national holiday so that it expands
who can vote maybe we also
uh have more access to who gets to run
to who gets in the debates
what if like making it a law and
everyone votes we actually that's the
first step in actually like
fixing the system so we can hear from
more andrew yangs we can't get the unity
party on the ballot we can do because
now it's all like
oh we all kind of have this
responsibility
so let's fix it so maybe you would
actually
want to vote in it you know what i mean
yeah i hear what you say
there's this excellent book by james p
cars called finite and infinite games
a vision of life as play impossibility
and one of the things he says is that
the first rule of play
is that he who must play cannot play the
moment you
require it it ceases to be the thing
that it is now
i believe that our two primary sources
of power in a voluntary society
is voice and exit it's the ability to
say what we really think
or it's the ability to opt out of
systems that we believe in
and that ability to opt out of systems
that we believe in by saying
i am going to invest my energy in
building up alternatives
or in focusing on other things is a huge
source of power
and it doesn't really get talked about
in the context of the political religion
that i criticize but we wouldn't have
the freedom to
not vote unless there was a certain
source of power
that lied in our ability to say i choose
not to play by the rules of this system
i choose to question the validity of
this system i choose to criticize
it as a system that is not actually what
it's presented to be
yeah this is helping uh well i brought
it up at the end of the minimal about
you know if you don't vote then
i feel like you shouldn't have a right
to rant about politics but this is
changing my mind like i can totally see
what you're saying like the and i've
heard people say that
well me not voting that is actually me
exercising my vote and what you just
said
has it's helped me actually see that
point of view well then also
one one point to that is you know
because i hear that criticism as well if
you're not going to vote then you don't
have a you then you can't complain
and but the thing that i complain about
the things i complain about are things
that neither choice would fix
they're not running on fixing those
things so i can complain about it all i
want
and still withhold my vote for either of
those candidates because neither of them
were campaigning on anything that i
wanted them to face
you guys want to know the line i heard
because i felt that for a very long time
and i loathe the democratic
establishment even though
i still consider myself a liberal but
the line that got me
this election season that was like
pissed milkshake um was
sharon salzberg who is a buddhist
meditation teacher
um she had a line in her book um
where they go well you know there's only
a marginal difference
between biden and trump and she goes but
people live in those margins
and that's when i was like that's why if
i were to voted for either of those two
i i'm planning on third party or writing
in but yeah i think i would lean trump
you really trump for that yeah i would i
would have i think if i lived in a swing
state
yeah i would have you know i probably
after everything i think i would have
probably
gone for trump expand on that um i think
he is
less i think the people that live in the
margins are the people who are in our
foreign policy is i think our number one
issue in this country we warmonger all
around the world
yes um we don't have the effects on us
here in this country so we seem to be
kind of putting the blinders on but to
me
death like life and death is first and
foremost because you can't make any
other decisions if you're dead
right so war is number one and then
that's when i put
medicare for all or health care system
number two because that's also life and
death
but the war issue trump has been
since depending on your definition uh
you could maybe say carter or you could
if you don't agree with carter because
of his role in the mujahideen in
afghanistan you could go back to ford
he's the first president to not put new
boots on the ground in any country
and that is a huge huge thing i mean he
has ramped up in some
areas and uh but definitely tried to
dwindle back in others but there are
people that live in those margins and
those margins happen to be places like
syria and afghanistan
i love that you're saying that i mean
i've become like homies with tulsi i'm
like a huge fan of hers um
and the and i got in a lot of trouble
for we were just talking about this in
our little bathroom break um i got a lot
of trouble when i went on conan
and i like obama the obamas as people
but i criticized obama for a lot of his
drone strikes and people were not happy
about that
and so i agree with you 100
i do wonder however if
what would happen if there was an attack
on american soil under trump because we
saw
when he tried to undo a lot of the
progress we've made with iran
now it was with rhetoric nothing
happened and i think people were like
and like pulled him back um from that
but we don't
we don't know you know like how what
would trump's reaction be
to i mean we see what happens when trump
gets a mean tweet he's just like he goes
to
he goes to war like what happened but i
think we do know i think we do know
because
look any any president knows and if he
really wanted to win
a second term any president knows in
order to win you just start a war
yeah sure and he has had every
opportunity to go to war
every opportunity to dispose leaders
such as in venezuela
and he had both sides championing him on
for that
and he just refused to do it i mean he
just does the bully talk
and he said oh you know you will unleash
the full force of america
yeah because that's all i hear right
i've never seen he doesn't do it but
then he doesn't ultimately go through
with it right and even though he had
every single warmonger on both sides i
mean we saw it even at the state of the
union address
where both democrats and republicans
stood up and cheered
for guido in and they want regime change
down in venezuela and they would have
wanted it militarily yeah
and trump is the one that said matt okay
we'll try it your way you know he's kind
of said to all of the warmongers around
him
okay we'll do it your way for a minute
and then when we're done with your way
and when your way has failed we're doing
it my way
and that has been the criticism people
have made where while he put more boots
on the ground in afghanistan or he did
more
strikes in syria or he did you know
tried to do the the
regime change in venezuela but
ultimately he was doing it their way at
first and then he turned around because
this was all in bolton's book
that you know he came out bolton
criticized trump for being basically
somebody who was saying we need to get
out bolden one of the most insane
warmongers
like of all time this is jamie kelsey
and same vote for trump um
but then what do you think about the
healthcare this is so interesting
because i really never thought of it
that way because you're right
i will always hear you just hear the
bully talk and the tweets yeah
and yeah i've never really been like a
showman right like oh there are no
um i i still i do wonder what would
happen if there was
an attack on domestic uh soil and i mean
one could argue uh we've seen violence
go up when it comes to like white
supremacy uh in america under trump
right
but what about with the the health care
do you think that
undoing i'm not a fan of obamacare um
i think it was just kind of a
wishy-washy thing that pissed off both
sides yeah um
but do you think that getting rid of
some of the things
that uh like if we got rid of obamacare
so for example like the pre-existing
conditions
especially under covid which is more of
a conservative
thing does that go against what you were
saying about healthcare being your
number two yeah you know i think it's
interesting the republican party i think
is totally transformed under trump and i
don't think there's any going back as
much as mitch mcconnell
and a lot of these other guys that are
the old guard of the republican party i
think they would like for it to return
back to normal
yeah and i think they're going to be
surprised to find out it will not
and if the republican party successfully
which they might if they were in power
successfully were to overturn obamacare
and get rid of it
the quickly the base which is now the
working caller you know blue collar base
of the republican party
would start screaming saying now what
are you going to give us and they will
have to replace it
they will not be able to get away with
just going back to the way it was prior
to obamacare right right
so it would be interesting to see i just
don't think we can go back and i think
the constituents and the voters would
just
the on the republican side would would
take i think it's just such a popular
healthcare now people are used to it and
once people are used to it
you can't take it away from them